في الاول هي موهبه رسم فقط لا غير رسمته
ودريت المنظر الوحش في العربيه وشكلها بقى
احلى وعجبت الناس قوي فانا كنت واخداها
موهبه بس مش اكتر وبعد كده ابتديت ان انا
استغل الموهبه دي في ان هي تكون مصدر دخل
لي او رزق ليا فبتستخدمتها كمان هنا وعجبت
الناس جدا والفن ده عامه مش منتشر قوي في
مصر يعني اللي بيرسموا العربيات قليلين
جدا مش عدد كبير خالص
[موسيقى]
انا دنيا عاشور عندي 25 سنه بكالوريوس
خدمه اجتماعيه الصغيره يعني بحب الرسم هي
حاجه شغفي الوحيد يعني هو الرسم طبعا بحب
حاجات كتير قوي بس الرسمه بالنسبه لي يعني
في حياتي يعني عامه الحكايه ابتدت معي ان
انا في البدايه اصلا يعني برسم عادي زي اي
طفله وبعد كده ما كبرت شويه من بدايه
ثانويه ابتديت ان انا يعني اتقن الرسم
شويه او اعرف ان انا بعرف ارسم اصلا يعني
صحابي هم اللي كانوا بيشجعوني بصراحه في
المدرسه في البيت اهلي كانوا بيشجعوني ان
انا ارسم جه الموضوع من خلال ان انا رسمت
على العربيه عربيه كانت مخدوشه حبيت ان
انا اداري العيوب اللي فيها والخبطات
الموجوده فيها ورسمت على العربيه فعلا
وعجبت الناس جدا من ساعتها يعني وانا
تعرفت بموضوع الرسم على العربيات لكن انا
برسم على حوائط وبرسم على لوحات وبرسم على
قماش وبرسم على شنط وعلى جلد يعني بحب
الرسم عامه بحب الفن اصلا فمن خلال كده
انا برسم كل حاجه وبعد كده جه موضوع
العربيات يعني اتعرفت بموضوع العربيات
اكتر لكن انا برسم على اي ماتريال يعني في
الاول هي موهبه رسم فقط لا غير رسمته
ودريت المنظر الوحش في العربيه وشكلها بقى
احلى وعجبت الناس قوي فانا كنت واخداها
موهبه بس مش اكتر وبعد كده ابتديت ان انا
استغل الموهبه دي في ان هي تكون مصدر دخل
لي او رزق ليا فبتستخدمتها كمان هنا وعجبت
الناس جدا والفن ده عامه مش منتشر قوي في
مصر يعني اللي بيرسموا العربيات قليلين
جدا مش عدد كبير خالص وعشان كده الموضوع
مش منتشر فبالتالي في ناس بتطلبه اصلا
انها ترسم على العربيات
[موسيقى]
في خبطات بتبقى موجوده احنا بنعمل لها
ديزاين بعملها ديزاين معين فبتدي شكل
جمالي في النهايه ان انا بداري العيب بشكل
حلو قوي وبيعجب الناس ودي حاجه مميزه
ومختلفه و ثانيا كمان العميل مثلا ما
بيجيلي بيبقى طالب مثلا حاجه معينه هو
عجباه هو فالرسم اليدوي بمختلف جدا عن اي
حاجه الهاند ميد يعني بيبقى حاجه طبيعي
خاص لك انت ما بيبقاش حاجه معينه مثلا او
حد راسم نفس الكلام ده لا بيبقى الموضوع
مختلف مميز بالنسبه لك ثانيا بتعمل اللي
انت عايزه وما حدش تاني بيبقى عامل نفس
الكلام يعني انا لما برسم لحد حاجه مش
بعملها لغيره هي اكتر رسومات الناس بتحبها
اكتر اللي هي الدودلز والمانديلا لشغل
اللي هو الحديث شويه او المودرن مش شغل
قديم يعني العميل لما بيطلب مني حاجه
بنفذها هو بيبعت لي مثلا صور بنقترح على
بعض بناخد افكار ثانيا بيرجع للدماغ
العميل بشوف الاول هو الصايله ايه هو بيحب
ايه بيحب الوان ايه بيحب ايه مع بعضه
وبالتالي بنركب افكار مع بعض مع بعض
الحاجه المناسبه للعربيه او للبايك او
للخوذه يعني ايا كان او للحوائط يعني
بنستغل بافكار بعض مع بعض عامه وانا برسم
اصلا انا بحب قوي وانا برسم بحس ان انا
اشغفي كله بيطلع انا بعمل حاجه دي بكل حب
فيا بعمل الحاجه دي عشان يعني نفسي في يوم
من الايام الناس تقول دي ده شغل دنيا
عاشور فده اللي انا عايزه اوصله مش عايزه
اوصل لمبالغ كبيره او الكلام ده خالص انا
برده ما بشتغل بشتغل من مبالغ قليله او
بسيطه عن ناس كتير طبعا في المجال يعني
الا اني انا حابه اظهر موهبتي اكتر من ان
انا باخد منها فلوس او هي ك- يعني مش مهنه
بس بحب اعمل حاجه مختلفه وبحس ان انا
فخوره بنفسي لاني مش شبه حد يعني بحس ان
انا يعني احب قوي ان كل الناس تكون نفسها
بس في النهايه ان انت تكون ليك بصمتك ليك
شخصيتك ليك كيانك مش بتقلد حد يعني احنا
مش كوبي من حد لا كل واحد يكون نفسه فبحس
ان كلنا هننجح لو كل واحد شاف هو بيحب ايه
او شغفه ايه هينجح اكيد من غير ما يبص لحد
او من غير ما يقلد اي حد في الدنيا يعني
[موسيقى]
هو الرسمه العربيات هو مخالف تمام زي
الاستيكر او الفاميه والكلام ده لكن في
ناس اصلا بتجيلي عامه هو مش مخالف بالنسبه
لها لان العربيه بتاعتها بتكون لونين
فبالتالي انا برسم لها بنفس اللون التاني
فهي ما تكونش مخالفه للعميل خالص وثانيا
في ناس كتير بترخص بالشغل ده او مثلا لو
انا عامله لها لون فهي بتروح الترخيص
وبترخص بلون تاني فبالتالي هي ما بتكونش
مخالفه هنا احنا مش معرضين في القانون في
اي حاجه وثانيا كمان لو رسمنا مثلا حاجه
بسيطه تداري الخبطه اللي موجوده او العيب
اللي موجود فبالتالي شكلها بقى جمالي
وثانيا كمان مش ملحوظه برضو حاجه بسيطه
فبالتالي هو كمان يعني التكلفه بتبقى اقل
عليه من الرش العربيه او الكلام ده كله
عشان ما يقللش من تمن العربيه اصعب حاجه
في الشغل ده هو مش قصه اصعب حاجه وانا
وجهت صعوبات كتير جدا هو مجال صعب مش سهل
على فكره وبقى لي كثير قوي انا باسعى في
الموضوع ده وبحاول اطور من نفسي يعني
داخله في المجال مثلا بقالي تسع سنين او
اكتر الواحد تعب كتير قوي وقست كثير قوي
واكيد في انتقادات سلبيه كتير جدا فالناس
ما بتعرفش تدي نقض بناء كلنا يعني ايه
اللي هو انت بتشخبطي انت فاشله انت مش
هتعملي اي حاجه انت مش هتوصلي لاي حاجه
فانا عايزه اقول لاي حد ان انت هتوصل لو
عايز توصل انت هتوصل فما يعني ما تسمعش اي
كلام وحش لان كده كده في النهايه لو عايز
تنجح انت هتنجح ده قرار
[موسيقى]